Das Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch.
Wir hatten einen Umsatz von 16 Millionen Euro und wir hatten ungefähr, ich sag mal, Verbindlichkeiten in der Größenordnung von 25 Millionen. Meine Aufgabe ist es nicht, jeden Wunsch zu erfüllen. Meine Aufgabe ist es, jeden Wunsch zu erfüllen, wenn man ihn erfüllen kann. Natürlich fragt der eine, warum gehst du nach China? Aber ich glaube, das haben sehr, sehr, das haben alle verstanden, dass das etwas ist, um Möglichkeiten der Zukunft auszuloten, um zum Beispiel die Eigenständigkeit im Verein zu bewahren. Oder wir würden uns zurückziehen, wir sagen, jetzt machen wir Borussia Mönchengladbach nichts mehr mit China. Das ist doch lächerlich.
Na, warum? Hallo und herzlich willkommen im Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch Nummer 39. Mein Name ist Max Jacob Ost, ich bin der Genetzer auf Twitter. Ihr habt ihn im Intro schon gehört. Wir hatten die große Freude, mit Stephan Schippers sprechen zu dürfen. Er ist Geschäftsführer von Borussia Mönchengladbach, und zwar nicht erst seit vorgestern, sondern seit ziemlich genau 20 Jahren. Er ist außerdem Aussichtsratsmitglied in der DFL und er ist Mitglied im DFB-Vorstand. All das hat dazu geführt, dass wir ein paar Fragen mit ihm besprechen wollten. Was macht man denn zum Beispiel als Geschäftsführer? Und die Interviews mit ihm sind so rar gesät, dass ihr jetzt auch im Intro ausnahmsweise mal schon Dinge gehört habt, die jetzt in der Folge gesagt werden. Normalerweise suche ich da ja immer andere O-Töne zusammen. Stephan Schippers steht nicht so gerne in der Öffentlichkeit und deswegen freuen wir uns sehr, dass er sich für den Rasenfunk dann über eine Stunde Zeit genommen hat. Man kann natürlich nicht alle Themen ansprechen in dieser einen Stunde, aber wir hoffen, dass dennoch ein sehr interessantes Gespräch für euch herausgekommen ist und damit schon mal Danke fürs Einschalten. Diejenigen, die den Rasenfunk vielleicht jetzt zum ersten Mal hören, wir sprechen auch über die Bundesliga, wir sprechen auch über internationale Ligen und vor allem, wir sind Sponsoren und paywall-frei und deswegen, bevor es losgeht, danke ich noch ein paar Menschen exklarisch für ganz viele Supporterinnen und Supporter. Nämlich in dieser Folge sind das Severus Tape, Daniel Pflege, Dorian, Jakob, Stechos Cactus, Rob, Günther Graß-Narbe, Philipp und Sebastian. Sie alle unterstützen den Rasenfunk finanziell und schaffen es, dass es den Rasenfunk gibt und dass er ebenso unabhängig bleiben kann, wie er aktuell ist. Herzlichen Dank dafür. Und das ist jetzt eine Besonderheit. In dieser Folge kann ich auch ankündigen, es gibt auch jetzt einen anderen Weg uns zu unterstützen, nicht nur über direkte Überweisung, ihr könnt auch Merch vom Rasenfunk kaufen. Unter kiosk.rasenfunk.de haben wir faire, schicke, schöne Sachen hergestellt, die ihr kaufen könnt und ein kleiner Beitrag des Preises ist dann eben auch Unterstützung des Rasenfunk vielleicht ja auch etwas für Geburtstage, Weihnachten und so weiter und so fort. Aber jetzt würde ich sagen, hören wir auf mit dem Gespräch über den Rasenfunk. Wie wichtig ist das, was Stephan Schippers zu sagen hatte? Hören wir ins Gespräch rein und bitte. Stephan Schippers, freut mich sehr, dass Sie im Rasenfunk mit dabei sind. Herzlich willkommen.
Ja, vielen Dank Herr Oster.
Ja, schön, dass Sie da sind. Wir wollen ein bisschen mit Ihnen drüber sprechen. Was macht eigentlich ein Geschäftsführer eines Bundesligisten? Und Sie haben ja auch noch eine ganz besondere Biografie, da kann man das so ein bisschen nach erleben. Sie haben am 1. Juli 1999 angefangen hier, das ist vor 20 Jahren gewesen. Sie waren damals 31 Jahre alt. Ich bin jetzt 34. Wie hätte denn mein Leben verlaufen müssen, damit ich Geschäftsführer der Borussia hätte werden können? Wie kam es denn dazu?
Ja, da wissen Sie ja mehr als ich über Sie auf der einen Seite. Also angefangen habe ich am 11. März 1999, das war mein erster Tag. Mein erster Tag, als ich bei der Borussia angefangen habe auf der Bürkelstraße. Auch mit jungen Jahren aus heutiger Sicht, das ist vollkommen klar, aber bei einem wunderschönen Verein und auf Ihre Frage zurückkommend, was zeichnet ein Geschäftsführer eines Bundesligisten aus, das kann ich Ihnen nur aus der Betrachtungsweise unserer Borussia sagen. Ich war noch nie von einem anderen Verein. Ich bin nur von Borussia Mönchengladbach oder zum Glück nur von Borussia Mönchengladbach Geschäftsführer gewesen. Was es dann auszeichnet, glaube ich, ist so ein bisschen die Flexibilität. Es gibt so einen schönen Leitspruch bei uns hier, bei Borussia. Jeden Tag was Neues. Es passiert jeden Tag was Neues. Der Sport ist so facettenreich, wunderbar, wunderschön. Und im Speziellen bei Borussia Mönchengladbach sind wir in den letzten zwanzig Jahren durch vielerlei Regionen, Facetten eines Vereins gegangen.
Oh ja, da werden wir jetzt gleich auch noch mal gemeinsam drunter durchgehen. Aber was war denn vor? Sie sind in Gladbach geboren. Sie haben BWL studiert und haben die Steuerberaterprüfung abgelegt, so wie ich es verstanden habe, auch relativ kurz bevor sie hier angefangen haben. Aber wie kam es denn dazu? Ich vermute, dass damals nicht eine Ausschreibung stand in einem örtlichen Medium oder hier irgendwelche Laternen bepflasterbar mit, möchte jemand Geschäftsführer der Borussia werden?
Das war die Aneinanderreihung von Zufällen sicherlich auf der einen Seite, aber zentrales Element ist, zwei Wochen bevor ich angefangen habe, hat der Königs angefangen bei Borussia Mönchengladbach. Er wurde ins Präsidium gewählt und mit ihm war ich schon im regen Austausch in Hinsicht eines Berufswechsels. Und so kam es dann auch mit der Ansage, Herr Schippers, wir machen das, aber lassen Sie uns bitte sechs Monate über Borussia Mönchengladbach nachdenken. Und aus den sechs Monaten sind jetzt etwas mehr geworden.
Und Berufswechsel heißt dann aus dem Steuerexpertentum hin zum Geschäftsführer?
Ja, jeder Mensch hat ja so eine gewisse Vorstellung, was er später beruflich mal machen will. Und meine Vorstellung war ganz klar die, ich möchte gerne in die Unternehmensführung gehen. Sagen wir die Ausbildung, das Studium, auch das Ablegen des Steuerberaterexamens war da Mittel zum Zweck. Und Borussia Mönchengladbach ist mittlerweile ein mittelständiges Unternehmen mit der Außenwirkung einer großen Kapitalgesellschaft. Es ist ein wunderbarer Beruf, ein wunderbarer Arbeitgeber und sehr facettenreich. Und das ist das Besondere, das ist das Salzen der Suppe, jeden Tag aufs Neue.
Jetzt war ja damals aber die Situation noch ein bisschen eine andere. Das war die Saison 1998-99, da ist Gladbach zum allerersten Mal abgestiegen. Seit dem neunten Spieltag war man damals Tabellenletzter. Das war das dramatischste Abstiegsfinale der Bundesliga-Geschichte. Und die Glad-Borussia hatte nichts damit zu tun, weil man leider schon sicher abgestiegen war. War denn das damals eine attraktive Aufgabe? Wussten sie überhaupt, was sie da erwartet?
Man konnte nicht wissen, was einen da erwartet hat. Aber man als Gladbacher Junge aufgewachsen auf der Birkelstraße, Fan dieses Vereines – das muss ich einfach so attestieren – war das natürlich eine Frage, die darfst du keine Menschen, der so aufgewachsen ist, stellen. Der sagt sofort Ja. Und mit 31 Jahren ist man ja noch jung, flexibel, hatte die Ausbildung im Rücken, eine junge Familie gegründet. Und da war die Herausforderung schon sehr groß und sehr schön. Das war natürlich vieles im Argen. Aber deswegen hat sich die Frage auch gestellt seiner Zeit. Und das war eine wunderbare Aufgabe dann, mit dem neu gewählten Präsidium, mit dem einen oder anderen Kollegen, der da war. Sicherlich mit dem einen oder anderen Kollegen. Durch den Abschied bedingt hat sich der eine oder andere Kollege, hat uns verlassen. Wir haben neue gesucht, wir haben neue gefunden und haben versucht, die Borussia wieder dahin zu bringen, wo sie aus unserer Sicht halt auch hingehört. Nämlich definitiv in die 1. Fußballbundesliga.
Das sollte ja dann auch klappen und jetzt reden wir gerade am Vortag des Spitzenspiels gegen FC Bayern. Also für alle diejenigen, die diese Folge mal später hören werden. Wir sprechen hier gerade mit einem Tabellenführer, Geschäftsführer. Wie war denn dann damals Ihr Beginn hier? Von Uli Hoeneß weiß man die gerne erzählte Anekdote. An seinem ersten Tag hat er sich einen Anzug angezogen, hat sich in sein Büro gesetzt, vier Stunden lang telefoniert und dann ist er wieder heimgefahren. Und er hatte nichts anderes als einen Notizblock in seinem Büro. Was war in Ihrem Büro?
Das prägnanteste, sagen wir mal gar nicht, was in meinem Büro war. Im Büro gab es erstmal gar nicht. Da wurde was frei und da waren große Begehrlichkeiten drauf. Mir ging es nicht um das Büro. Wie gesagt, 11. März hat es begonnen und als Fußballbundesligist gibt man die Lizenzunterlagen immer bis zum 15. März ab. Ich habe den damaligen Kollegen gefragt, wie sieht es denn aus mit der Lizenzierung? Gibt es da größere Probleme? Und größere Probleme gab es nicht, weil die Liquiditätslücke, die da war, war entscheidend für ihn so prägnant und gegenwärtig, dass das nicht erwähnenswert war. Und dann hat man relativ zügig – mit diesem Präsidium sind wir in Richtung Frankfurt gereist und haben mit dem DFB, mit dem Herrn Straub seinerzeit noch Kontakt aufgenommen und gefragt, wie ist es möglich, dass wir vielleicht nicht die ersten sind, die er prüft, sondern gibt uns ein bisschen Luft. Wir sind gerade frisch und wir sind gerade neu und sind mit vollen Aufgaben nach Hause gefahren und haben geguckt, dass Borussia Mönchengladbach für die Saison 1999-2000 eine Lizenz erhält. Und das ist uns dann auch gelungen – mit viel Hilfe des DFBs, aber auch mit viel anderer Hilfe. Und das war die erste große Tat, um überhaupt Borussia Mönchengladbach im Spiel zu halten – zwar in der zweiten Liga, aber auch im Spiel zu halten. Und aus dem ist dann das passiert, was wir heute hier sehen.
Und wie muss ich mir da dann das Entgegenkommen des DFBs vorstellen? Also sicher zeitlich, dass man da nicht gesagt hat, ok, wenn es jetzt nicht am 15. März um 12 Uhr hier auf dem Tisch liegt, dann gibt es große Probleme. Das ist ja wahrscheinlich relativ einleuchtend. Wie läuft so ein Lizenzierungsverfahren ab oder wie ist es vor allem damals abgelaufen? Es war ja auch noch eine andere Zeit.
Es war eine ganz andere Zeit und trotzdem damals ist es abgelaufen, dass Herr Straub ganz klar gesagt hat, ich muss alle ersten zwei Digisten natürlich durchschauen und bis dann die erste Rückäußerung kommt, habt ihr Zeit, um eure Liquiditätsloch zu decken. Abgabefrist war auch einzuhalten, der 15. März. Das war auch alles vorbereitet und den Weg sind wir dann auch gegangen. Aber das größere Problem war ja praktisch in dem, wie soll ich das sagen, im Herleiten, in dem Organisieren der Liquidität.
Wie groß war denn die Lücke?
Auch, wir sagen immer so schön.
Jetzt können sie es ja sagen, es verjährt.
Wenn ich heute zurückblicke, rechne ich direkt den Euro. Warum? Wir hatten einen Umsatz von 16 Millionen Euro und wir hatten ungefähr, ich sage mal, Verbindlichkeiten in der Größenordnung von 25 Millionen. Und das heißt, wenn ich aus dem heutigen Sicht das sehe, wenn du den 1, 3-fachen Umsatz als Verbindlichkeiten hast, hast du aber keinen Stadion und bist gerade abgestiegen oder hast den Blick ganz klar in die zweite Liga, dann waren das schon Herkulesaufgaben, die dazu bewältigt waren. So immer so, warum für den gesamten Verein?
Können Sie mir erklären, in meinem Verständnis nach, ein normales Wirtschaftsunternehmen müsste da schon Insolvenz anmelden. Warum musste es dann die Borussia in dem Fall nicht?
In dem Fall konnten wir guten Gewissens das nicht machen. Man redet dann von stillen Reserven in Spiele und dergleichen, aber wir sind niemals gezwungen worden, aus heutiger Sicht auch spitz auf Knopf zu rechnen. Wir haben ein Testat bekommen über unseren Jahresabschluss, das war da, das war da und das war auch wichtig. Aber wir hatten natürlich, ich sag mal, ausreichend Liquidität dann organisieren können und dadurch dann auch die Bonität, die nächste Spielzeit zu überstehen. Und das war das Signal in Richtung Frankfurt zu sagen, okay ihr kriegt die Lizenz für die zweite Fußball-Bundesliga. Es sind ja dann gleichzeitig auch Spieler von uns gegangen, muss man auch sagen. Und es ist auch ein Spieler beispielsweise von uns gegangen, der vielleicht keinen Vertrag hatte oder zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo man dann im Endeffekt ablösen erzielen können. Und da weiß ich noch Norbert Flippen leider noch heute nicht mehr unter uns. Ein Gladbacher, praktisch für mich so ein wenig der Erfinder als das Spielerberater Daseins. Der hat dann dafür gesorgt, dass wir für den ein oder anderen Spieler auch Geld erhalten haben, wo man vielleicht spitz auf Knopf ist, hätte nicht erhalten müssen. Also da hat schon jeder versucht zu helfen, wie man helfen konnte. Das war ein nicht uninteressanter Weg. Borussia Mönchengladbach 1999. Das kann man so festhalten.
Das hört sich auch nicht uninteressant an. Wussten denn damals alle Beteiligten, dass Herr Flippen da vielleicht noch mal Geld rausgeholt hat?
Also auf unserer Seite, Borussia Seite, wussten das alle Beteiligten, ja.
Und wie lief damals die Entscheidungsfindung ab? Also Sie haben ja schon angesprochen, man musste sich damals von einigen Spielern trennen und gleichzeitig versuchen, so schnell wie möglich wieder in die erste Liga aufzusteigen. Sollte ja dann auch mit einer Ehrenrunde in der zweiten Liga geklappt haben. Wie war denn damals die Entscheidungsfindung, was sportliche Belange anging? Es gab das Präsidium, es gab Sie, aber es gab ja noch keinen Sportdirektor, keine Manager, also die Strukturen waren noch andere als heute.
Ja, ein bisschen anders schon. Wir waren organisiert im Verein, im EV. Da gibt es nur das Präsidium, das ist richtig. Und der Geschäftsführer, den gibt es nicht, sagen wir mal, wie bei uns im Handelsrecht oder in der GmbH, sondern dann war ich dann der Geschäftsstellenleiter, so hieß die Nomenklatur. Wir hatten den Sportdirektor, das war Christian Hochstetter, der hatte ja auch, was weiß ich, kurz vorher auch die Aufgabe übernommen. Und er war maßgeblich derjenige, der den Kader mit dem Trainer zusammen natürlich dann für die kommende Saison zusammenstellen musste und zusammengestellt hat.
Und waren Sie dann als Leiter der Geschäftsstelle die Wand gegen die er gerannt ist, bei allen finanziellen Wünschen, die man da äußern kann?
Man muss wahrscheinlich sagen, leider ja. Das ist einfach so. Meine Aufgabe ist es nicht, jeden Wunsch zu erfüllen. Meine Aufgabe ist es, jeden Wunsch zu erfüllen, wenn man ihn erfüllen kann. Und ich sage mal ganz lapidar gesagt, Fakt ist, wir hatten uns einerzeit auf die Fahne geschrieben, nur das Geld ausgeben zu wollen, was wir auch definitiv verdienen. Und ich habe es eben gesagt, was hatten wir an Verbindlichkeiten da? Was hatten wir an Infrastruktur? Was hatten wir an Stadion? Was hatten wir an Mannschaften? Und die Aufgabe war es im Endeffekt, diesen Verein neu auszurichten. Und relativ zügig hat das Presidium nochmal mit Dr. Jordan, und der auch mittlerweile verstorben ist ja leider, und auch Herrn Königs, Herrn Söllner und ich. Am Anfang war Herr Jakobs noch als Präsident dabei. Das Ziel auch ganz klar dingfest gemacht. Du musst ein neues Stadion kriegen. Du musst leider von der Bökelstraße weg, aber die ganze Infrastruktur, alles das, was an Möglichkeiten der Vermarktung war, auch für Presse, Funk und Fernsehen, da war es wichtig, ein neues Stadion zu kriegen und zu kreieren. Und wir sind dann auf den Weg gegangen, haben unsere Schulden abgebaut. Auf der einen Seite haben wir den Aufstieg im Fokus gehabt, auf der anderen Seite, das ist ja 2-1 dann geglückt mit dem Hans-Major als Trainer. Und auf der anderen Seite war es dann so, dass wir gesagt haben, wir waren dann irgendwo in 2002 mit Baubegehend des Stadions und 2004 hier Bezug dieses Stadions, unseres Borussia-Parks, soweit, dass wir gesagt haben, jetzt haben wir das Kapitel hinter uns und jetzt müssen wir uns um die weitere Zukunft von Borussia Mönchengladbach kümmern.
Sie haben mal gesagt, ohne den Borussia-Park wären wir heute wahrscheinlich analog zu anderen Vereinen mit schlechter Infrastruktur und unzureichenden Trainingsbedingungen in der dritten oder vierten Liga. Jetzt haben sie gerade schon so ein bisschen umrissen, warum das so ist. Infrastruktur, höhere Einnahmen, bessere Arbeitsbedingungen für Medien, VIPs und so weiter. Aber erklären Sie mir doch mal, wie ist es denn überhaupt dann möglich, einen Stadion zu finanzieren, wenn man mit einem solchen Schuldenberg antritt?
Ich glaube ganz stark, dass die Akteure aus dem Präsidium, auch speziell Herr Königs, als Unternehmer dieser Stadt, auch ein gewisses Renommee hatte und auch dieses finanziell solide Renommee ausgestrahlt hat. Man hat diesem Präsidium, man hat uns geglaubt, dass wir ernst machen und wir haben Stück für Stück zusammengetragen. Wir haben die Schulden beseitigt, wir haben die Struktur bereinigt, wir hatten mehrere Gesellschaften, wir haben alles zusammengeführt. Wir haben dann praktisch ausgegliedert, wir haben gesagt, es gibt nachher in unserer Idealform unseren Verein, die Borussia, und es gibt eine Kapitalgesellschaft, wo dann alles das drin ist, was da heißt, Stadiumbau und später Betrieb, Mannschaft, Vermarktung und dergleichen. Und so sind wir gegangen. Wir haben die Hilfestellung von der Stadt Mönchengladbach bekommen, wir hatten hier ein Gebiet im Fokus, wo wir überhaupt hätten bauen können und auch gebaut haben. Die Stadt Mönchengladbach hat uns auch, ich sage mal zinsvergünstigt, aber nicht zinsfrei, ein Darlehen gewährt. Das war wichtig, sagen wir mal, mit Hinblick auf den Stadionbau. Und die Landesbürgschaft und das ganze Konglomerat hat es uns dann ermöglicht, ich sage mal, 2002 in die Erde zu gehen, wenn man so schön sagt. In Mönchengladbach sind zehn Jahre vorher die Bagger ja gerollt, aber dann fingen sie an zu rollen und 2004 dieses Stadion auch dann fertig zu haben.
Jetzt gibt es viele schöne Zahlen, die man im Vergleich setzen kann zu ihrer Anfangszeit und zur Jetztzeit. Also damals, sie haben es ja auch schon genannt, 17 Millionen Euro Umsatz. 20 Mitarbeiter habe ich in einem Artikel gefunden, in einem anderen waren es 40. Definitiv sind es jetzt viel, viel mehr. Also aktuell sprechen wir eher von einem Umsatz von 180 Millionen plus X und über 200 Mitarbeitern, um es so zu formulieren. Nennen sie mir doch mal die Rahmenbedingungen, in denen ein Verein damals agiert hat. Denn das, dass die Bundesliga-Vereine gewachsen ist, das ist ja auch tatsächlich im gesamten Markt passiert. Das heißt, viele Vereine haben nicht genau die identische Entwicklung, aber eine solche Entwicklung hinter sich mit eben sehr stark wachsenden Umsatzzeiten. In welchem Rahmen hat man denn um die Jahrtausendwende als Bundesliga-Verein agiert? Wir sprechen da ja auch um die Zeit, in der dann die Kirchpleite nochmal den ganzen Markt so ein bisschen vor existenzielle Fragen gestellt hat.
Ich mache gerne einen Vergleich. Wir haben uns in den letzten 20 Jahren irgendwo vor zwölf-Facht als Borussia Mönchengladbach, wenn man nur auf den Umsatz schaut. Und auf der anderen Seite glaube ich, dass in den letzten zehn Jahren der professionelle Fußball sich ungefähr verdoppelt hat einmal. Vor dreifach vielleicht. Das sind die Relativprozente am langen Ende. Die Zeiten sind anders geworden. Alles das, was heißt Vermarktung, das was heißt Medien. Wenn ich mich zurück erinnere an den Bökelberg, hatten wir einen Parkplatz. Der wurde aber in der Woche als Aschenbolzplatz genutzt. Das war unser Wipp-Parkplatz.
Hätte heute wieder einen vermarktbaren Charme.
Ja, das ist vollkommen richtig. Aber ich glaube, die Kollegen, also auf der einen Seite die Sportler, die dann über einen frisch gefrorenen, eben befahrenen Boden dann wieder den Ball spielen müssen, das ist ein Problem, auch mit Gesundheit. Und auf der anderen Seite, wenn ich dann alleine sehe, was wir hier an TV-Compound in Neudeutsch, was wir hier vorhalten müssen und vorhalten, was wir hier, damit im Endeffekt die Bilder aus dem Stadion eins zu eins, was weiß ich, in alle Länder transportiert werden können.
Also die Infrastruktur für die Fernsehübertragung.
100 Prozent. Das sind Anforderungen. Das ist ein Quantensprung, das hätten wir gar nicht machen können auf der Birkelstraße, auf dem Birkelberg. Und selbst wenn man gewollt hätte, wenn man gut gespielt hätte, hätten wir da keine Spielerlaubnis bekommen am langen Ende, weil die infrastrukturellen Maßnahmen gar nicht zukunftsweisend waren oder dann auch nicht für die jeweilige Spielzeit. Und deswegen war es uns allen relativ früh und relativ zeitig klar, du musst hier gucken, dass du ein Stadion kriegst, was du auf der einen Seite finanzieren kannst, was du dann aber auch perspektivisch dann auch gut refinanzieren und betreiben kannst. Und dazu ist der Borussia Park aus meiner kaufmännischen Sicht ein wunderbares Beispiel. Er ist der Schlüssel zum Erfolg. Das ist der erste Schlüssel zum Erfolg. Im Fußball gibt es viele Schlüssel. Kommen sie wahrscheinlich gleich auch nochmal drauf. Aber ich glaube, das war so die Schlüsselsituation, dass wir es geschafft haben, als Borussia Mönchengladbach dieses Stadion bauen zu können.
Und sich gleichzeitig nicht daran zu verheben. Den Stadionbau, den haben viele Bundesligisten und ehemalige Bundesligisten gemein. Einige haben sich allerdings auch daran verhoben. Das hat dann aber jetzt eigene Gründe. Da müssen wir jetzt, glaube ich, an der Stelle nicht drauf eingehen. Aber wie hat sich denn jetzt dann die Kirchpleite und das, was damals mit den TV-Geldern passiert ist, auf die Borussia ausgewirkt? Und wie kann man damit umgehen als Bundesliga-Verein? Das war ja durchaus dramatisch.
Ja, aber ich glaube, da hat die Liga relativ schnell eine relativ gute Lösung auch erarbeiten können. Und es gab eine gewisse Phase, ich erinnere mich dran, da hat der eine oder andere Kollege schon mal kurz den Atem angehalten, wofür das hin. Aber es gab ja relativ zügig, ich sage mal, auch Lösungen, sodass am langen Ende eine richtig ernste Situation aus Liquiditätsbetrachtung niemals gekommen ist. Es war eine anstrengende Situation, die aber auch sehr, sehr gut gemeistert worden ist. In Frankfurt muss man auch mal als Lob dann rüber spielen. Ich glaube, der Fußball hat sich seitdem sehr, sehr entwickelt. Und wenn man dann sieht, wie sich auch seitdem Christian Seifert die Führung der DFL übernommen, seitdem die DFL ausgegliedert worden ist, ist er dann auch der Vorstandsvorsitzende und die Vermarktung unserer Fußballspiele. Das ist schon ein Schlüssel dahin, dass wir sagen können, wo wir heute als deutscher Fußball auch sind. Natürlich Meilenstein, WM 2006 im eigenen Land. Das sind alles so Facetten, die gerade in die Fußballinfrastruktur viel hineingebracht haben.
Wobei wir dazu jetzt sagen müssen, sie sind Aufsichtsratmitglied bei der DFL. Also sie müssen natürlich auch Christian Seifert jetzt hier loben.
Ich würde es nicht tun, wenn es nicht müsste.
Okay. Aber ich wollte es einordnen für die Hörerinnen und Hörern, die ja nicht den gleichen Kenntnisstand haben können wie wir beide, vor allem natürlich wie sie. Jetzt haben wir schon immer wieder als indirekt über Fernsehgelder gesprochen. Können Sie mir mal am Beispiel der Borussia ein bisschen erklären, wie sind die wirtschaftlichen Verfasstheiten bei einem Bundesligisten? Welche Rolle spielt Fernsehgeld hier? Was sind die anderen Einnahmequellen?
Ich glaube, der Grundsatz, also die Fernsehgelder sind die größte Einnahmenposition bei Borussia Mönchengladbach. Aber ich möchte nur über Borussia Mönchengladbach reden. Es gibt Vereine, da kann man drauf neidisch sein oder nicht. Da ist das sicherlich nicht die größte Einnahmenposition.
Ich glaube, es gibt nur einen Verein in Deutschland, bei dem das so ist. Dortmund knapp, Bayern auf jeden Fall, und Nagenthal ist größer.
Genau. Aber trotzdem für uns als Fußballverein, ich sag mal in der oberen Tabellenhälfte, auch vom Umsatz her angelagert, so irgendwo auf dem Platze. Das ist ja schwierig zu beziffern, weil der ein oder andere Verein nicht veröffentlicht. Aber vom subjektiven Empfinden über die jahre gereift die Überzeugung, dass du irgendwo diesen siebten Platz hast, dass du irgendwo diesen achten Platz hast vom Umsatz, da ist das die größte Einnahmenposition. Und die wird zentral und seit langer Zeit auch sehr gut in Frankfurt gehändelt für uns Bundesligisten und Zweitligisten, wo ja alle vier Jahre wieder der Streit drüber entbricht. Wie sollen wir die ganzen Gelder dann verteilen? Aber ich glaube, und das ist der Liga gut gelungen, das ist also ein wichtiges Standbein für jeden Club, um entweder sein Etat bestreiten zu können.
Und dann haben wir ja noch weitere Einnahmen. Wir haben die Spieltagseinnahmen. Da hat dann eben auch das neue Stadion hier wesentlich für bessere Konditionen für den Verein gesorgt. Wir haben tatsächlich dann ja auch noch die Mitgliederseite, das dann eher den EV betrifft. Da gab es auch einen krassen Anstieg von, ich glaube, 6.000 Mitgliedern, so rund um die Zeit, als sie begonnen haben, bis hin jetzt zwischen über 90.000. Sind das dann noch die wesentlichen weiteren Einnahmen plus Merchandising?
Man muss sagen, die nächste große Einnahmenposition ist das Sponsoring, also die Vermarktung vom Spiel, vom Spieltag. Dann ist es natürlich, wenn du dich international qualifizieren solltest, ist das immer ein wunderbarer, warmer Regen, den du als Verein dann auch bekommst. Es ist natürlich, wichtig ist natürlich, die Zuschauereinnahmen, die du als Fußballclub erwirtschaftest, die sind sehr gut. Und dann kommt Merchandising, dann kommt aber auch schon Catering. Also sprich, dass die Wurst, das Bier, bis hin zu den Veranstaltungen, wie hier bei Borussia Mönchengladbach machen, so round about 800 bis 900 Veranstaltungen außerhalb einer Fußballveranstaltung pro Jahr hier. Das heißt, dass der Fan, der kann seinen Geburtstag feiern, der kann genauso gut, kann eine Firmenveranstaltung stattfinden, eine Hauptversammlung. Also wir sind hier sehr variabel, was weiß ich, von 10, 15 Personen bis 2.500 Personen hier unterbringen zu können. Das machen wir sehr erfolgreich und in dem Zufolge ist das auch eine gute, eine interessante Position in deiner G&V.
Und welche, kann man da die prozentualen Aufteilungen so ein bisschen aufgliedern? Fernseh-Einnahmen, wie groß ist der Teil ungefähr an den Einnahmen, die man hat? Spieltagseinnahmen und Sponsoring?
Fernseh-Einnahmen jetzt auf das Jahr betrachtet von Borussia Mönchengladbach, über die nationale, wie die internationale Fernsehvermarkte, sind rund 40 Prozent. Du hast rund, ich sag einfach mal, 13, 14 Prozent hast du Ticket-Einnahmen draußen, außer WIP-Tickets. Du hast rund 20 Prozent in der Vermarktung, 25 Prozent Vermarktung, was das Thema Sponsoring bedeutet. Und dann gliedern sich die restlichen Beträge so auf.
Und finden Sie, finden Sie es kritisch, dass man dann so von den TV-Geldern abhängig ist, also die anderen Töpfe? Wir haben jetzt die Größe eben, deswegen habe ich die Frage gestellt. Wir wissen, diese Töpfe sind nicht marginal, also da kommt auch viel Geld. Aber das Wichtigste ist eben auch bei einem so gut aufgestellten Verein wie Borussia Mönchengladbach immer noch das Fernsehgeld. Und wo sich ja immer die Frage stellt, schafft man es mit jeder neuen Rechtevergabe, die Frage wird ja jetzt bald wieder beantwortet werden, da nochmal etwas drauf zu packen.
Ich glaube, jeder sieht, wenn man eine Einnahmeposition hat, in der Größenordnung, die ich gerade nannte, 40 Prozent, dann ist das auf der einen Seite ist es was wunderbares, wenn man kriegt das Geld und auf der anderen Seite ist natürlich, wenn du von einer Position in der Relation stark abhängig bist, musst du da auch stark darauf achten. Und diese Position verändert sich durch sportlichen Erfolg, national wie international, wenn du spielst. Das ist das, was der Club beeinflussen kann und das andere ist das, was im Endeffekt die Liga erwirtschaftet, alle vier Jahre, wie sie angesprochen haben und wenn dann auch diese Erlöse erzielt werden und sie nachher verteilt werden. Aber ich denke, das gehört im Fußball einfach dazu, dass du in dem Bereich Fernseh-Einnahmen einfach deine Hauptposition hast. Und wenn wir jetzt sagen würden, das wäre der Umkehrschluss, die Position ist mir zu risikobehaftet, zu groß. Ich möchte lieber viele kleine Töpfe haben, können wir ja gerne darauf verzichten. Aber dann habe ich einen Kollegen, den Max, der sagt, auf den Pod können wir nicht verzichten, was absolut nachvollziehbar ist.
Also Max Eberl in dem Fall, nicht zu verwechseln mit dem Max, der hier moderiert, für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen. Eindeutig war da nicht ich gemeint. Glauben sie denn, dass der Fußball darauf vorbereitet wäre, dass irgendwann dieser Punkt der Fernseh-Einnahmen nicht mehr wächst?
Ich glaube, jedem muss doch klar sein in der jetzigen Situation, dass wir erst mal einen riesen Schritt gemacht haben zu der jetzigen rechten Periode. Dass wir nicht davon ausgehen können, dass der nächste Schritt analog groß sein wird. Wir hoffen natürlich, dass wir zumindest den Status, den wir dann haben werden in der letzten Saison dieser rechten Periode erhalten bleiben. Vielleicht sogar gibt es einen kleinen Schnaps obendrauf. Dafür wird gearbeitet. Aber das ist im Risikokalkül eines jeden drin. Der muss kalkulieren. Das kann auch mal einen kleinen Schritt in die andere Richtung gehen. Aber das muss jeder Verein für sich selber berücksichtigen. Wie gehe ich mit den Fernsehgeldeinnahmen? Ich muss vielleicht ein bisschen ausholen. Innerhalb einer rechten Periode – wir reden von vier Jahren – steigern sich ja die Gelder von Jahr zu Jahr. Ob ich dann unbedingt eins zu eins die Steigerung des letzten Jahres noch unbedingt direkt mit in die Ausgaben bringe oder vielleicht, wie man so schön sagt, ein bisschen in die Risikoposition bringe, um zu schauen, was passiert. Das ist das eine. Aber es sind natürlich auch Spielergehälter und auch Transfergeschäft ist natürlich sehr stark abhängig, wie die Fernsehgelder sind. Also selbst wenn irgendwas sich verändern würde, auf der Einnahmenseite, dann wird ja sehr volatil auch die Ausgabenseite drauf reagieren. Natürlich hast du Verträge, die musst du dann auch einhalten. Aber es ist doch vollkommen klar, dass dann, sagen wir mal, auch in der Saison zwei oder drei danach, dass dann auch mit den Gegebenheiten auch nur gewirtschaftet werden kann. Das heißt, der eine oder andere Spieler wird dann weniger verdienen, der eine oder andere Verein wird dann wahrscheinlich für einen Spieler weniger auch nur kriegen im Verkauf oder im Einkauf auch weniger zahlen. Das wird sich dann anpassen. Das sind fast kommunizierende Hören, das muss man einfach so dann sehen. Und so mal so machen, glaube ich, ist der deutsche Fußball, was ich betrachten darf, auf sehr soliden und stabilen Füßen.
Es wird jetzt ein bisschen wirtschaftstheoretisch, aber den Punkt finde ich sehr wichtig mit Blick auf die Zukunft des deutschen Fußballs. Es gibt Netzwerkeffekte und auch Ökonomen, die entsprechendes Prophezeien, die sagen, ja, für den deutschen Fußball ist es natürlich so, wenn bei allen die Einnahmen an einer Stelle stagnieren, zurückgehen, egal wie, dann spüren das ja alle. Aber gleichzeitig ist ja der deutsche Fußball auch eingebettet in den europäischen Fußball, wo man eine Konzentration auf die Premier League erlebt, auf die Champions League, wo die großen Gelder, die bezahlt werden, in andere Märkte fließen. Haben sie da nicht die Sorge, dass das dann auch indirekt auch einen Verein wie Borussia Mönchengladbach trifft?
Also erstmal stehen wir nicht alleine da, aber Summa summarum, wir können ja nur die Rahmenbedingungen, die wir haben, mit denen können wir nur leben, mit denen können wir nur wirtschaften. Ein schönes Beispiel ist doch, dass Borussia Mönchengladbach in den letzten acht Jahren immer einstellig abgeschlossen hat, die Saison. Das hat Bayern gemacht, das hat Borussia Dortmund gemacht und wir. Es gibt drei Vereine, die es gemacht haben. Wir zählen aber wirtschaftlich nicht zu den drei stärksten Vereinen in der Bundesliga. Und genauso muss man es, glaube ich, auch einen Blick nach draußen sehen. Es muss in gewissem Kontext geben, wie wir deutschen Vereine, gerade die Vereine, die sich auch international bewegen, sagen wir mal, welche Gelder in die Vereine fließen, damit man auch gute und sportlich starke Euroleague-Mannschaften oder auch Champions League-Mannschaften los schickt. Aber immer nur zu sagen, die Engländer, die Engländer, die Engländer, das wäre mir zu kurz gesprungen. Das ist nun mal so, dass auf dem englischen Pay-TV-Markt wesentlich mehr Geld erzielt wird. Das ist nun mal so. Wir können es hier nicht ändern. Wir können nur unsere Hausaufgaben machen und das so gut wie möglich auch kreieren. Und am Ende des Tages, das ist immer mein Gefühl, natürlich ist Geld viel wert, aber am langen Ende ist es nicht alles. Und ich glaube, das zeigt Borussia Mönchengladbach auch immer wieder, dass wir aus den Mitteln, die wir haben, die sind sicherlich mehr als vielleicht ein ein oder andere Verein jetzt nicht hat, aber andersrum auch gibt es viele Vereine, die wesentlich mehr haben. Und du musst die Relativprozente gut machen. Wir sagen immer so schön hier, du musst halt immer noch mal den weiteren Weg gehen und du musst noch mal den steinigeren Weg gehen. Und das macht gerade im sportlichen Bereich und den Erfolg macht. Eines Vereines macht im Wesentlichen der sportliche Erfolg, also der Sport selber. Sei es bei uns über die Jugend, sei es über das Scouting, dass du Talente siehst und sichtest, aber sei es auch darum, dass der Max mit dem Trainer, der andere Max, nämlich der Max Eberl, dass er im Endeffekt immer wieder eine Mannschaft zusammenstellt, die das Potenzial hat, interessant im Fußball zu spielen und auch, sag ich mal, in der Bundesliga in der oberen Tabellenhefte zu sein. Das ist ja immer so eine Wellenbewegung. Immer wieder sehen wir ja, wenn wir wirklich einmal sportlichen Erfolg hatten, dass uns vielleicht der eine oder andere Spieler abhandengekommen ist, ob man das will oder nicht, ob man das finanziell muss oder nicht. Und trotzdem ist es, wie gesagt, der ganzen sportlichen Truppe unter Anleitung vom Max gelungen zu sagen, da ist wieder ein Kader, da ist wieder für den Verlust des einen Spielers ist eine Lösung gefunden worden, die führt dazu, dass wir im Endeffekt einen Fußball haben, der uns Spaß macht. Ich rede jetzt nicht, ausdrücklich nicht, über Tabellen Platz 1. Wir lassen uns da sicherlich kein Sand in die Augen streuen. Das ist ein wunderschöner Nebeneffekt, dass man in der jetzigen Phase oben ist, aber wir wissen, alle 13. und 14. Spieltag, eine Schwalbe macht noch keinen Sommer.
Alles gut, da werde ich sie jetzt in keine Meisterschaftsprognosen krein drängen. Das können gerne andere machen an der Stelle. Aber wenn wir jetzt gerade schon über Max Eber sprechen, dann würde mich mal interessieren, wie funktioniert denn die Zusammenarbeit? Und was ist so genau ihr Tätigkeitsfeld? Man liest nicht so wahnsinnig viel von ihnen. Wenn man dann sich auf Suche begibt, dann kann man Beschreibungen lesen, wie sie seien der Herr der Zahlen bei Borussia Mönchengladbach. Wie würden sie sich selbst denn beschreiben?
Also erstmal glaube ich, dass es eine wesentliche Tugend ist, dass nicht jeder, der in einem Fußballverein arbeitet, meint, er müsste unbedingt in der Außendarstellung, was weiß ich, sich im Fokus und im Zentrum sehen.
Ich meinte das auch nicht, Nigga.
Das ist ein Vorteil. Wir haben den Trainer, der jeden Tag zu sprechen hat, auch nach draußen, und den Max, der auch sehr stark draußen ist, weil da geht es um Sport. Da geht es um den täglichen Sport, da geht es um die Saison, da geht es dann auch Saison übergreifend. Das interessiert den Fußballfan doch wirklich. Der Fußballfan freut sich doch am Ende des Tages, wenn sein Verein nicht in die negativen Schlagzeilen durch irgendwas anderes hineingerät. Und wenn sie fragen, was ich zu tun habe, kann ich so sagen, alles außer Sport. Also das weiß ich, alles, was hier im Stadion stattfindet, das heißt, so ein Stadion zu betreiben, das er läuft, das er seinerzeit gebaut worden ist. Aber nicht ich, sondern das Team von Borussia Mönchengladbach. Wir haben ja eine erweiterte Geschäftsleitung, muss man sagen. Da sitzen jeden Mittwochmorgen neun Kollegen am Tisch. Das ist der Max Eberl, der Stephan Corell, der Roland Virkus, der Herr der Jugend. Und dann sitzen auf der anderen Seite, sitzt da ein Markus Arets, ein Guido Ule, ein Michael Plummer, ein Bernhard Nießen und ich. Und wir sitzen zusammen und unterhalten uns im Endeffekt, sagen wir mal, was ist die letzte Woche passiert, was passiert in der nächsten Woche. Und dementsprechend sind die ganzen Aufgabengebiete zu bearbeiten. Aber das interessiert ja am langen Ende den Fan von Borussia Mönchengladbach nicht. Er will reibungslos ins Stadion kommen. Er will im Stadion sicher sein. Er will seine Wurst in der richtigen Temperatur und das Bier, ein schönes Spiel, seine Fanartikel bekommen. Und das ist auch sein gutes Recht. Und dazu sind wir Dienstleister, die wir das auch machen müssen und gewährleisten müssen. Und deswegen ist es, glaube ich, eine der schönsten Tugenden Reden des Silberns, Schweigen des Gold. Im Podcast geht das nicht.
Deswegen freue ich mich, dass Sie hier sind.
Deswegen ist das hier der erste, den ich habe nach 20 Jahren.
Das freut mich auch wirklich sehr, dass Sie sich die Zeit nehmen. Aber ich glaube ein bisschen, Sie meinen es nicht so, aber ein bisschen unterschätzen Sie Fans damit. Denn wenn Sie den Fan fragen, möchtest du in der nächsten Saison die Meisterschaft und dann aber vielleicht, dass wir uns in fünf Jahren wirtschaftlich so verhoben haben, dass wir den Weg antreten, den andere Vereine auch schon gegangen sind, nämlich, dass man zu einem Pendelverein zwischen erster oder zweiter Liga wird oder sogar noch schlimmeres. Oder möchtest du ein solides Wirtschaften, dann wird er natürlich hin und wieder mal grummeln, wenn man dann gegen Augsburg zu Hause eins zu eins spielt. Das ist jetzt tatsächlich auch ein Beispiel aus der Geschichte von Borussia Mönchengladbach, müssen wir jetzt aber nicht nochmal hervorkramen. Aber ich glaube schon, dass das für Fans interessant ist. Und natürlich ist das eine mit Emotionen behaftet und das andere eher mit Vernunft. Und die Emotionen gewinnt kurzfristig immer über die Vernunft. Aber es ist doch sehr wichtig, dass es Leute gibt, die über den sportlichen Erfolg hinausdenken. Denn das eine ist garantierbar, das andere nicht.
Also sie haben vollkommen recht. Ich glaube gerade auch bei Borussia Mönchengladbach, weil wir diese Geschichte hatten mit 99. Und wir sind in der Phase sehr lang über den Stadionbau, über praktisch so das USB der Zukunft gesprochen haben. Das heißt gesagt haben, wenn wir mal das Stadion haben, dann passiert dies oder jenes und das. Und man hat es all die Zeit nicht geschafft. Ich bin fest davon überzeugt, dass unsere Fans sehr aufgeklärt sind und sehr nah dabei sind und das auch vernehmen. Das meinte ich gerade nicht. Aber es ist doch viel schöner, wenn man sich dann nur über den Sport kümmern kann und das Restliche im Hintergrund ist. Ich bin 100 Prozent ihrer Meinung, dass das das das ist das das wirtschaftliche wirtschaftliche Fundament. Das ist doch gerade erst die Plattform, dass du anständig auch im Sport wirtschaften kannst, dass du dich entwickeln kannst, dass du die Möglichkeiten haben, wenn du Geld einnimmst, dieses Geld auch wieder in den Sport hineinzustecken. Es ist doch nicht schlimmer, ein Loch mit dem anderen zu stecken. Das war ja früher, wurde immer mal wieder gefordert. Aber jetzt musst du doch mal, was weiß ich, den Spieler oder den Spieler doch verpflichten. Und das wird dann schon der sportliche Erfolg der Zukunft dir zurückzahlen. Aber so geht das aus unserer Sicht. Vielleicht geht das aber aus unserer Sicht nicht so. Denn wir sagen, wir können nur das Geld ausnehmen, was wir einnehmen. Wir haben hier bei Borussia Mönchengladbach zwei Arten noch von Verbindlichkeiten. Das ist einmal ein Bereich, was liegt hier noch auf dem Stadion? Das ist ungefähr in der Größenordnung von 43 Millionen Euro. Und wir haben am langen Ende drüben noch 20 Millionen Euro von unserem Gebäude Borussia Achtgart, das wir als Anfang des Jahres eröffnet haben. Und das Summa Summarum bei den Werten, die geschaffen worden sind mit Stadion, mit dem gesamten Gelände, mit der Infrastruktur, mit Borussia Achtgart auf der immobilen Seite. Und wenn man sich dann die Werte anguckt, die die Mannschaft darstellt, das ist doch die Kenngröße, was hat Borussia in den letzten Jahren geschaffen. Und da stehen wir aus einem ganz gesunden Fundament. Ich sage immer sehr gerne, wir sind operativ, schuldenfrei. Wir haben keinen einzigen Spieler irgendwie refinanziert, über irgendein Konstrukt.
Und auch hier in Ihrer Amtszeit noch nie. Also seitdem Sie hier sind, oder?
Am Anfang hatten wir natürlich Schulden, die mussten wir abbauen. Aber es hat nichts mit meiner Amtszeit.
Aber Sie haben nicht neue Schulden aufgenommen, um einen Spieler zu verwerfen?
Nein, das haben wir nie gemacht. Aber nicht wegen mir, sondern wegen uns. Und Fußball ist ein Teamwerk, das ist das Präsidium. Das schwappt dann auf der einen Seite dann auch in den Situationen natürlich auch Schulter an Schulter mit dem Aufsichtsrat. Aber ganz entscheidend für mich auch natürlich unsere führenden Kräfte, die erweiterte Geschäftsleitung, die Kollegen, die ich gerade genannt habe. Das ist im Endeffekt das Team, was dafür sorgt, dass wir nämlich nicht da hinkommen. Aber ganz auf eine Schlüsselposition hat in der Sekunde natürlich der Max. Er könnte es sich ja leicht machen. Er könnte sagen, holt mal zu, Club, ich hätte gerne hier elf Messis. Ja, okay, andere Testegen muss ich auch noch haben, aber dann nehme ich zehn Messis und Marc-André und dann kann ich die sportlichen Ziele erfüllen. Nein, der Max weiß ganz klar, was wir können als Borussia Mönchengladbach, aber er weiß auch, was wir nicht können. Und er muss die Kreativität entwickeln, mit dem Recht zu kommen, was wir haben. Und nicht, warum auch immer sagen, jetzt lass uns doch nochmal Schulden aufnehmen, um den Spieler noch zu kriegen. Nein, und das ist einfach ein seriöses Wirtschaften, auch ein seriöses Miteinander. Als sie eingangs fragten, was zeichnet die Beziehung aus, dass der Max das auch versteht und das mitträgt. Und dann ist es ein Gemeinschaftswerk. Und dann geht man durch gute, jetzt haben wir eine gute Phase, aber man geht dann auch mal durch sportlich schlechtere Phasen. Und das zeichnet dann Borussia Mönchengladbach auf, das ist die Überschrift Kontinuität. Wir reden über 99 bis heute. Gucken wir uns vom Präsidium an, Rolf König, Siegfried Zöllner, seit her dabei. Markus Arez, nach einem Jahr gekommen. Guido Ulle war schon bei Borussia Mönchengladbach, der für das Sponsoring und für den ganzen Gastronomiebetrieb zuständig ist. Der Michael Plumm kam dazu, der Leiter der Verwaltung. Es kam dann auch der Bernhard Nießen dazu, als das Stadionbau sich so ein bisschen dann konkretisiert hatte bei uns. Die sind alle noch hier, das kann ich genauso jetzt durch die Abteilungsleiterebene ziehen. Das ist eine starke Kontinuität, die wir bei Borussia Mönchengladbach haben und das zeichnet sich aus. Die linke Hand weiß, was die rechte tut und umgekehrt und vor allem, an welchem Strang wir Gemeinschaften ziehen. Und das macht mich stolz.
Sehr schönes Plädoyer für Kontinuität. Wenn ich Unternehmensberater wäre, dann würde ich jetzt mit Agilität dagegenhalten, aber das möchte ich nicht. Sie haben Ihren Punkt gemacht und der soll auch gerne so und widersprochen stehen. Aber an welchem Punkt kommt denn dann ein Max Eberl zu Ihnen? Also wie funktioniert die eine Transferperiode zum Beispiel? Gibt es vorher einen festgelegten Betrag X, den Sie quasi in einer Kalkulation in Anführungszeichen freigeben, weil Sie sagen, okay, ich plane jetzt das nächste Jahr vor und dann kann man ja mit konkreten Beträgen kalkulieren? Wie funktioniert das?
Irgendwie vom Grundsatz, aber dann jeder Grundsatz hat die Ausnahme. Der Max ist ja jetzt schon an der Saison 2021 dran mit seinem Team. Das heißt, er macht ja jetzt schon Gedanken, wie sieht mein Kader jetzt aus? Wir alle haben draußen mitbekommen, Borussia Mönchengladbach hat den ein oder anderen bestehenden Spieler schon verlängert, also um diese Mannschaft der Zukunft praktisch zu machen. Das ist ein revolvierendes System. Das ist nicht so, als wenn wir sagen würden, jetzt haben wir mal Weihnachten, Weihnachten ist zu Ende und irgendwann im März werden wir wach. Was passiert eigentlich jetzt? Irgendwann haben wir Saisonende Mitte Mai. Welche Spiele sollen wir denn mal gucken? In welche Richtung brauchen wir Verteidiger und Stürmer und Torwart? Ne, das ist ganz anders. Der Max hat ja einen Mehrjahresplan aus sportlichen Sicht, den er natürlich mit dem Trainer abstimmt, wo die Scouts involviert sind, die genau wissen, was weiß ich, in zwei Jahren wird diese Position mal fällig. Wahrscheinlich gibt es Ersatz und dergleichen. Und so werden verschiedene Targets ins Auge bezogen. Und von der kaufmännischen Seite ist es so, wir haben unseren Haushalt, wir wissen, was wir einnehmen werden, kalkulatorisch, und wir wissen auch, was wir auch ausgeben werden. Da sind wir auch relativ planungsdreu und trotzdem gibt es dann immer Sondereffekte. Das heißt, für uns ist ein Sondereffekt die Qualifikation zu einem internationalen Wettbewerb. Oder genauso gut, dass er rauskommt aus der zweiten Runde aus dem DFB-Pokal, das planen wir nie. Weil wir ganz einfach sagen, das ist wunderbares Geld, was du dann verdienst, wenn du es dann hast. Und genauso ist es dann auch, wenn, warum auch immer, Spieler den Club verlassen, verlassen wollen, und es dafür Geld gibt, dann ist das immer eine Zusatzeinnahme, die natürlich eins zu eins in den Sport geht.
Das heißt, wenn Sie über die Borussia nachdenken, denken Sie dann nicht nur bis zum Saisonende, denken Sie dann schon im nächsten Geschäftsjahr, denken Sie an in fünf Jahren, denken Sie an in zehn Jahren, also wenn wir an die Finanzen denken, haben wir immer so einen zwei-Jahres-Vorkast, dass wir genau wissen, in welche Richtung das geht.
Wir wissen ja, was verdienen wir in der Saison, was sind die Besonderheiten, die können wir dann raus eliminieren, was sind im Endeffekt die Rahmenbedingungen, wie beispielsweise der Fernsehgeldvertrag des nächsten Jahres, da wissen wir ja heute schon, was im nächsten Jahr kommt. Natürlich ist die Fragestellung, wie schließt du ab, die Fernsehgelder sind ja aber mehrere Töpfe zu zahlen, und da gibt es gewisse Planszenarien, und wir sind ein sehr konservativ planender Club. Wir sagen jetzt nicht so, den letzten Fennich, den wollen wir herausdrücken, weil am langen Ende hatten wir 99, das Hemd war zu kurz, und wir waren kurz, wie man so schön sagt, vor der Pleite. Das war ja nicht der Birkelberg, das war ja der Schuldenberg. So war es zumindest bei uns in der Reinigen Post, in der Zeitung mal zu sehen. Und wir planen konservativ, um zu sagen, böse Bereichungen sollte es nicht geben. Wir tun, was wir können, wir segeln da auch hart am Wind, dass wir, sagen wir mal, für den Sport das Maximale investieren, aber wir würden niemals irgendwie in irgendeiner Art und Weise unseren Verein in Bedulde bringen. Das darf nicht sein. Weil Sport ist in dem Sinne weitestgehend der Versuch der Planbarkeit, aber ist ja nicht planbar. Mir kann ja, oder uns kann ja keiner sagen, investierst du A, kriegst du B.
Ja, genau.
Und das muss man einfach mit der nötigen Ruhe machen. Und bei uns sind es Rahmenbedingungen, das Geld ist endlich und damit muss man umgehen.
Sehen Sie da Unterschiede zwischen Vereinen, die eine ähnliche Situation wie Gladbach schon mal hatten, also dass sie eben diese Situation hatten, schon mal kurz vor der Insolvenz oder zumindest große Lücken, die man zu stopfen hatte, zu anderen Vereinen? Sehen Sie da ein unterschiedliches Agieren im Markt Bundesliga?
Möchte ich mich nicht so äußern. Ich gucke soweit nicht, ich gucke nur auf Gladbach.
Das glaube ich Ihnen nicht, aber es ist in Ordnung, dass Sie dazu öffentlich nicht sagen wollen. Sie sind ja auch in einer DFL-Funktion und Sie haben ja unter anderem auch dafür gesorgt, wenn ich richtig informiert bin, dass zum Beispiel früher am Ende der Saison klar ist, welchen Rang der TV-Geld-Tabelle man dort belegt und die erste Tranche mit der gleich planen kann.
Woher wissen Sie das denn?
Das kann man über Sie herausfinden, wenn man ein bisschen Artikel liest.
Da müssen Sie aber schon verdammt tief gebohrt haben. Sie sind der Tat so, weil es ist ja aus der Planbarkeit heraus nicht nachzuvollziehen, wenn ich am 15. Mai meine Saison beendet habe, dass ich dann weiß, welche Fernsehgelder kriege ich nächste Saison.
Ich fand das ehrlich gesagt irre zu lesen, dass das nicht immer schon so war. Wie hat man denn dann früher geplant?
Ich kann nur sagen, wie wir geplant haben. Wir wussten dann irgendwann am 34. Spieltag ja immer noch nicht, wie ist es denn dann am 34. Spieltag. Und dann waren es die Fernsehgelder, die im Ende Effekt für die kommende Saison zuständig waren. Da konnte man nur mit Abschlägen und immer näher ans Ziel ranrobben, so ungefähr. Denn in jeder Tabellensituation, ob in der Mitte, ob unten, sind natürlich in den letzten ein, zwei Spieltagen mit zwei Siegen oder zwei Niederlagen ruckzuck drei, vier, fünf Tabellenplätze zu verlieren oder zu ergattern. Und was hieß das, was hieß jeder Tabellenplatz? War mitunter eine Million Euro. Und das ist natürlich Geld. Und deswegen ist es richtig zu sagen, du schließt die Saison ab und dann weißt du in dem Moment, was du im Endeffekt in der übernächsten Saison bekommst. Und damit kannst du, eine Mannschaft wird ja geplant im Frühjahr. Die wird ja nicht geplant später. Und dann kannst du im Frühjahr auch sagen, was du dir leisten kannst, weil du sechs Monate vorher praktisch dein Goge kriegst, das was an Fernsehgeldern ist.
Und dann stimmt es also, dass sie damit verantwortlich waren, das zu ändern?
Das war von uns eine Initiative, in der Tat. Aber das habe ich noch nie draußen gelesen, gehört. Insofern müssen sie in Ecken bohren, die kenne ich noch nicht.
Das waren jetzt keine, das waren öffentlich verfügbare Ecken, um es so zu sagen. Aber ja, ich habe mich vorbereitet. Jetzt haben sie ja in ihrer Zeit hier, wir haben ja schon, den Anfang haben wir ja schon relativ blumig bzw. unblumig eher von der finanziellen Situation her beschrieben. Sie hatten immer wieder besondere Momente, sowohl und dann spiegelt sich logischerweise immer das Finanzielle im Sportlichen, denn das beide kann man nicht komplett losgelöst voneinander betrachten. Das haben wir ja schon herausgearbeitet. Und da ist Gladbach sehr lange, natürlich auch aufgrund der finanziellen Last, konservativ aufgetreten. Man hat immer um die – ich nehme jetzt die Zahlen von transfermarkt.de – ich weiß nicht, wie valide die sind. Sie schmunzeln leicht, aber sie haben auch nicht laut gelacht. Sie können mich auch jederzeit gerne mit korrekten Zahlen korrigieren. Aber es wurden in den Anfangsjahren meistens zwischen zwei, drei Millionen Euro investiert in Spielertransfers, bei gleichzeitig weiter wachsenden Einnahmen auf anderer Seite. Also man darf da nicht nur die Transfers isoliert betrachten. Ich möchte es aber an der Stelle deshalb einmal tun, weil das ja der Bereich ist, wo das Sportliche mit dem Finanziellen eben aufeinandertrifft, wo Max Eberl und sie sich irgendwann in einen Raum setzen und dann auf welche Art und Weise auch immer zu einer Entscheidung finden müssen, ist und haben wir das Geld für diesen Spieler zum Beispiel. Und da hatten sie immer wieder so Momente, wo man das Gefühl hatte, jetzt ist Gladbach und mit mit Gladbach auch ein bisschen die ganze Liga in neue Dimensionen vorgetreten. Können sie sich noch daran erinnern, was so der erste Transfer war, bei dem sie sich gedacht haben, boah, also ich kann das jetzt finanzieren, aber das ist jetzt ein neues Gefühl zum Beispiel für einen Lüge de Jong einen kolportierten zweistelligen Millionenbetrag auszugeben oder?
Also ich würde das mal so beantworten von der Abgabenseite, als seinerzeit Marco Reus uns verlassen hat. Dann war das eine Dimension von der Einnahmenseite, die man vorher nicht kannte. Marco Reus hatte, das ist ja bekannt, das sind ja keine Einzelheiten, hatte eine festgeschriebene Ablösesumme und als wir seinerzeit bei der Vertragsverlängerung diese Summe praktisch uns auf diese Summe geeinigt haben, da war uns klar, das wird lange dauern, bis Borussia Mönchengladbach mal solche Erträge erzielt.
Da waren zwei Jahre dann.
Ja und da war sicherlich so ein Schritt zu verzeichnen. Aber bei dem einen oder anderen Spieler ist es ja auch heute noch so, dass Borussia Mönchengladbach, wir gehen immer noch konservativ ran, wir gehen immer noch in unseren Möglichkeiten ran. Denn ich glaube, in der Strategie des Clubs und auch ganz klar im Fokus von Max ist ja, dass er sagt, die Spieler am Ende des Tages ist ja so, wenn die Spieler zu uns kommen, die haben in ihrem Club den ersten Schritt gemacht, fallen uns auf, wenn sie nicht aus unserer Jugend kommen und fallen uns auf und machen dann den Schritt, in die Bundesliga vielleicht zu kommen. Vielleicht waren sie schon irgendwo in der Bundesliga oder der Zweiten Bundesliga und machen somit dann, in dem, wenn sie zu Borussia Mönchengladbach kommen, den zweiten Schritt, mittlerweile durch eine Vertragsverlängerung, den dritten Schritt in ihrer Karriere. Und wenn sie den Wunsch und den Willen und das Zeug dazu haben, dann auch den nächsten, den vierten Schritt zu machen, zu einem größeren Club zu gehen, ja dann hat der Spieler uns geholfen über eine Zeit von drei, vier Jahren auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite geht dann das Konzept so ein wenig aus. Wir wollen kein Ausbildungsklub sein, aber wir sind doch weit davon weg, dass wir sagen, wir können jeden Spiele halten, den wir wollen. Das muss man ja ganz klar und gewissenhaft sagen und so besser die Qualität der Jungen ist, die wir entweder hier ausbilden am Standort der Roland-Firkus mit seiner Truppe und oder aber wirklich auch junge Spiele, die zu uns stoßen. Wir haben ja Beispiele. Dann ist in der Bundesliga, sind es ja nahezu 17 von 18 Vereinen, die müssen dann auch verkaufen, wenn auf der anderen Seite jemand richtig kaufkräftig ist, das Verlangen ausübt so ungefähr.
Aber auf der Einnahmenseite gab es da nicht mal den Moment, bei dem dann Max Eberl, also ab 2008 war es dann Max Eberl, zu ihnen kam und gesagt hat, ich hätte gerne Spiel XY, der ist super, der ist toll, wir brauchen dafür Betrag X und sie dachten sich, puh, also ja, schaffen wir, müssen wir uns aber ganz schön strecken und man setzt das ja immer in Verhältnis zu dem, wie es 99 2000 losging und die Summen sind einfach so wahnsinnig gewachsen.
Die Summen sind gewachsen, 100% richtig, aber ich glaube, es geht ja auch darum, was ist die Philosophie hinter einer veränderten Situation. Als Beispiel, wenn ein Spieler, der warum auch immer uns verlässt, eine Lücke reißt im Kader, wie schließt der Club die Lücke und das ist halt nicht so, dass dann eins zu eins der gleiche Spielertyp gesucht wird. Das ist auch ein großes Stück Erfolgsrezept über die Jahre von Max und seiner Führung. Denn diesen Kader immer wieder zu erneuern auf eine Art und Weise. Es geht dir ein Marco Reus verloren, den Marco Reus kannst du nicht ersetzen. Es geht dir ein Granicciacca verloren, den Granicciacca kannst du nicht ersetzen. Dann hat er gesagt, dann lege ich vielleicht diese Verantwortung, dieses Potenzial auf zwei oder drei Schultern. Und insofern ist das, sagen wir mal, eine sehr intelligente Herangehensweise, aber du musst so flexibel sein, das auch immer wieder machen zu wollen. Denn das Schicksal wird Borussia Mönchengladbach aus meiner Sicht noch sehr, sehr lange folgen und tragen. Wenn es wirklich richtig, richtig gut geht, dann passiert das Schicksal, dass Spiele den Verein verlassen werden und dass wir nochmal wieder Anlauf nehmen müssen. Der größte Erfolg nach unserer ersten internationalen Qualifikation, also als wir dann unseren Platz 4 erreicht hatten und nicht die Qualifikation zur Champions League, aber als wir in der Euro League gespielt hatten und in der Bundesligasaison, haben wir parallel den achten Platz gemacht. Und da sagt Max, und das ist auch richtig so, sagen wir mal, das war der größte Erfolg, den wir machen können, den achten Platz zu kriegen. Wir haben es ja danach gesehen, bei anderen Vereinen hat es halt dann bis zum Abstieg gereicht. Und du musst als Verein dich langsam adaptieren und in diese Gefilde kommen und als gesamter Verein homogen wachsen, um den Anforderungen einer Dreierbelastung gewachsen zu sein.
Okay, so ein bisschen haben sich raus gewunden, aber ich lasse sie da jetzt auch raus. Wie viele – sie brauchen keine Namen nennen – wie viel Prozent der Transfers kommen aus finanziellen Gründen nicht zustande? Ist man da schon so aufeinander eingespielt, dass Max Eberl nur mit Vorstellungen zu ihnen kommt, die immer passen?
Man kann es so bezeichnen, da er die Rahmenbedingungen kennt und weiß, was der Verein imstande ist zu leisten. Also ich kann mich an keinen Transfer erinnern, wo am Ende des Tages das Samengeld gescheitert ist.
Wirklich nicht. Dann sind sie ein sehr gut eingespieltes Team in der Tat. Wie wichtig ist denn dann die Verteilung der Fernsehgelder – wenn wir noch mal auf das Thema kurz zurückkommen wollen – innerhalb der Liga für einen Verein wie Borussia Mönchengladbach? Da gab es viele Diskussionen darüber. Wir müssen da jetzt nicht im Detail darauf eingehen. Aber die grundsätzliche Situation ist ja so, dass die Schere zwischen den Vereinen, die durch die Fernsehgelder profitieren und den Vereinen, die – vor allem, wenn wir da mal auf die Zweitligisten gucken – sich ein bisschen abgehängt fühlen, die geht auseinander. Und gleichzeitig haben wir eine ähnliche Bewegung, wenn wir uns die verschiedenen Einnahmequellen – Champions League und Europa League – angucken. Also es macht einen deutlichen Unterschied, ob ich mich für die Champions League qualifiziere oder für die Europa League. Das ist fast schon grotesk, wie da die Fernsehgelder auseinandergehen. Ist das für einen Verein wie Borussia Mönchengladbach, der sich ja etabliert hat, der – sie haben es ja vorhin genannt – als einer von ganz wenigen Vereinen es geschafft hat, sich im einstelligen Tabellensegment der ersten Liga zu positionieren und damit ja auch in der TV-Gelt-Tabelle immer gut dasteht. Ist es wichtig, dass dieser Zustand beibehalten wird?
Also ich möchte jetzt sehr, sehr ungern im Vorfeld einer Ausschreibung der Fernsehgelder hier über alternative Szenarien oder sonst was reden. Es steht mir nicht zu als Teil der DFL, es steht mir vielleicht zu als Club, aber als Club haben wir ein Selbstempfinden, dass wir sagen, die Fernsehgelder – auf der einen Seite sind die Fernsehgelder der Vergangenheit doch immer sehr, sehr ausgewogen verteilt worden – Über alle 36 Clubs, die nationalen und auch die internationalen Fernsehgelder – ich rede nicht von Euroleague und Champions League – sehr, sehr ausgewogen und die ganzen Begehrlichkeiten von jedem Einzelnen versucht worden, mit in einen Topf zu werfen, um eine Quotierung zu geben. Es wird beispielsweise jetzt gewertet, wie viele junge Talente werden eingesetzt in der Mannschaft. Es wird herausgefunden, wie hast du die sportlich entwickelt in den letzten fünf Jahren, wie hast du die sportlich entwickelt in den letzten 10, 20 Jahren, wie hast du international was gemacht, je nachdem, an welchem Topf man ist. Ich glaube, das ist schon sehr, sehr faires und mit Augenmaß – das Verteilungssystem ist da implementiert worden, vor drei Jahren, für die jetzt laufende rechte Periode. Jetzt zu sagen, es gibt immer einen, der vielleicht sagt, ich könnte mehr haben, aber Bayern München könnte wahrscheinlich mit gutem Recht auch sagen, halt stopp, wenn ich in die Eigenvermarktung gehe, dann hätte ich noch mehr. Also wir müssen schon irgendwo versuchen, fair zu bleiben und auch alle zu betrachten. Aber sie haben es doch wunderschön in ihrer Frage gesagt. Ihr habt euch doch als Borussia Mönchengladbach in der Fernsehgeldtabelle, nicht nur in der sportlichen, sondern auch Fernsehgeldtabelle, richtig gut etabliert. Ja, das steht doch jedem offen.
Das stimmt natürlich, aber man könnte auch, ohne die Leistung, die sportliche Leistung und auch ihre Leistung von Borussia Mönchengladbach schmälern zu wollen, könnte man aber auch sagen, dass die Borussia da eine gesegnete der Zeit ist. Denn das war noch möglich in einem Zeitraum, in dem die Bundesliga noch volatiler war, vom Abschneiden der Vereine her. Und man hat aktuell den Eindruck, dass man sich als etablierter Erstligist – also ich spreche jetzt nicht von Mannschaften, die mal aufsteigen, wieder absteigen, mal aufsteigen, wieder absteigen, sondern von Mannschaften, die eben genau das schaffen, sich in der oberen Tabellenhälfte oder rund um die Tabellenmitte zu etablieren – dass das als Verein, der nicht dort schon steht, nur noch möglich ist durch externe Geldgeber. Also wenn ich mir angucke, wer hat sich nachhaltig in der Bundesliga etabliert in den letzten Jahren über einen längeren Zeitraum, dann sprechen wir mit der TSG Hoffenheim von einem Verein, der von einem mit zehn Anschub finanziert wurde und inzwischen durch Transfererlöse jetzt auf eigenen Beinen steht. Und wir sprechen mit Rasenballsport über einen Verein, der ebenfalls aktuell, wenn ich jetzt allein nur auf das Transferseite gucke, noch sind die da auch sehr im Minus. Also kein anderes Modell hat es geschafft, sich langfristig da zu etablieren.
Ich glaube, da sind wir ein anderes Beispiel. Und nur zu sagen, früher war das möglich und heute nicht.
Ich glaube, dass sie im richtigen Zeitpunkt nämlich dann als auch die Fernsehgerder so angestiegen sind.
Das sind genauso Diskussionen, wenn ich mich mit meinem Sohn unterhalte und ihn nach seinem Abitur frage und sagte, ja, es war viel schwerer als bei dir. Und jede Zeit bringt seine Möglichkeiten, aber auch seine Schwierigkeiten mit sich. Wir haben irgendwo zehn Jahre haben wir restrukturiert und Stadien gebaut und alles gemacht und die letzten zehn Jahre einen, sagen wir mal, auch im Sportfuße gefasst. Und wir sind ja wirklich, wir sind aus der zweiten Liga, sind wir angetreten. Natürlich mit dieser fantastischen Marke Borussia Mönchengladbach, mit diesem fantastischen Club, mit diesem fantastischen auch, sagen wir mal, mit dem Fundus aus den 70er Jahren, mit den Meisterschaften, Pokalsieg, mit allem drum und dran. Das ist natürlich, da ist halt der Hebel wesentlich größer. In der Sekunde, wenn du wirklich ehrlich, mit ehrlicher, harter Arbeit antrittst, dass natürlich du Emotionen aus den 70er Jahren wecken kannst als Borussia Mönchengladbach. Das ist unser Standortvorteil und den kann uns auch keiner nehmen. Das ist fantastisch, aber zu sagen, es geht nur über den einen Weg, dass jemand Geld ins System steckt. Ich kann doch auch den Brückenschlag zu den Kollegen aus Frankfurt schlagen. Die haben ja auch durch ihren Pokalsieg einen richtigen Schub erfahren. Und deswegen wäre ich mich dagegen zu sagen, das heutige System ist nur noch irgendwo beeinflussbar, wenn du dich extern aufstellst, was weiß ich, durch 50 plus 1 ausnutzen oder 50 plus 1 sogar abschaffen oder was weiß ich, welche Diskussionen hier alle da sind. Wir sind andere Überzeugung. Natürlich gibt es dafür auch Zeiten, die sind schwieriger. Da musst du halt den steinigeren Weg gehen und vielleicht kannst du das Geld nicht ausgeben, was du gerade wolltest. Aber nachhaltiger ist es, glaube ich.
Aber glauben sie, dass es noch den anderen Weg gibt, in dieses geschlossene System Profifußball reinzukommen, wenn wir jetzt mal vielleicht von den Top 25 Mannschaften in Deutschland sprechen?
Ich glaube daran. Sonst würde ich doch im Umkehrschluss sofort sagen, wir müssen unbedingt, um das Gleiche auf den oberen Rahmen der oberen Tabellenhefte der Bundesliga zu abstrahieren oder vielleicht über die Qualifikation Euroleague, Champions League, dann müssten wir doch sagen, das schaffen wir ja nie mehr. Weil da sind ja andere Vereine gesetzt, wenn ich mal aufzähle. Wenn wir nur über die Finanzen die Möglichkeiten – was ist mit Bayern, München, Dortmund, Wolfsburg, Leverkusen, Leipzig, Hoffenheim – dann sind dort die Startplätze schon mal weg. Dann müssten wir doch uns Gedanken darüber machen, wie kriegen wir Fremdkapital hier oder Eigenkapital, welches Modell auch immer, wie kriegen wir das hier rein bei Borussia Mönchengladbach. Weil die Sehnsucht ja groß ist, auch international zu spielen. Wir sind davon überzeugt, genau diesen Weg zu gehen. Oder auch, dass man sich Möglichkeiten sieht, als Beispiel die Bayern, die Kollegen aus München, die haben es ja auch sehr gut gemacht. Die haben 25, 24, 9 Prozent ihrer Anteile weg. Wir haben drei große Anteilsgeber dabei, aber das sind auch alles strategische Partner, das sind, sagen wir, strategische Sponsoring. Also wenn man an solchen Gedanken denkt, dann ist es für uns ja auch immer gangbar zu sagen, okay, wenn du Anteile eines Tages verkaufen würdest, Klammer auf, wir müssten und wollten über die Mitgliederversammlung gehen, das haben wir bei uns in den Statuten stehen, dass wir keinen Schnellschuss machen können, auch nicht unsere Nachfolger. Um dann zu sagen, strategisches Sponsoring, gesellschaftsrechtlich mit einem kleinen Anerkennungsbetrag zu unterlegen, das kann ja immer der Weg sein. Aber das ist nicht heute der Weg.
Aber wenn wir jetzt schon beim Weg heute sind, dann würde ich gerne mit Ihnen über die Internationalisierungsstrategie von Gladbach sprechen. Sie haben ein Büro in China eröffnet, da zeichnen auch Sie ein bisschen mit verantwortlich für, zumindest in der Außendarstellung habe ich das so wahrgenommen. Was ist denn der Gedanke dann, als Borussia Mönchengladbach auf den chinesischen Markt zu gehen? Rechnen Sie damit, dass ganz viele Chinesen zu Fans die Raut in ihrem Herzen entdecken.
Das ist doch wunderschön. Jeder assoziiert etwas damit. Was macht Borussia da gerade? Worum geht Borussia Mönchengladbach hin? Sie haben recht, dass man sich erstmal die Frage stellen muss, hast du die Größe, hast du die Strahlkraft als Borussia Mönchengladbach, als Verein, der rechnerisch vielleicht in den letzten Jahren jedes zweite Mal international gespielt hat, dass du es dir erlauben kannst, einen solchen Markteintritt zu begehen? Das haben wir mit ja beantwortet. Warum haben wir das mit ja beantwortet? Weil wir der festen Überzeugung sind, dass wenn wir uns überlegen, wo sind die Geschäftsfelder der Zukunft, dann sind wir uns alle oder wir sind uns bei Borussia klar, dass wir sagen, die Eintrittsgelder, die haben ein Maß, das ist gut, das ist verträglich, das können wir perspektivieren, wollen wir auch gar nicht, denn Fußball muss bezahlbar bleiben. Wir sagen immer, Fußball ist ein Sport, so wie wir ihn lieben, der muss bezahlbar sein, der Vater muss mit seiner Tochter, mit seiner Frau, mit seinem Sohn, wie auch immer, zum Fußball gehen können, das muss er sich leisten können. Wir haben es ja gesehen in Italien, als man Eintrittspreise so drastisch erhöht hat und das hingeführt hat. Das ist das eine. Das andere, die Fernsehgelder, die können wir nicht beeinflussen. Das wird zentral sehr, sehr gut von der Liga gehändelt, das können wir nicht beeinflussen. Das können wir nur mittelbar über unseren sportlichen Erfolg oder Misserfolg versuchen zu beeinflussen. All die Einnahmenquellen und das Thema der Internationalisierung ist ja nicht ein Thema, dass wir sagen, wir wollen jetzt in China in einem Land, wo 1, 4 Milliarden Menschen leben, vielleicht sind es auch doch ein paar noch mehr, da wollen wir nicht hingehen und sagen, die müssen jetzt alle mit unserem Trikot rumlaufen. Aber vielleicht ist es ja so, wir haben die Möglichkeiten innerhalb der Bundesliga ja über virtuelle Werbung zu reden. Und wir haben zum Beispiel einen Partner in China, der bei selektierten Spielen auf unserer Werbebande virtuell eine andere Werbebotschaft ausstrahlt. Das merkt hier im Stadion und in Europa merkt das keiner, aber das kommt in Asien vor, in China speziell. Und das führt dazu, dass wir dort Einnahmen generieren. Wir sind so, wir sind jetzt seit anderthalb Jahren in China vertreten und das haben wir gemacht, weil wir gesagt haben, wenn wir diesen Schritt gehen wollen, dann wollen wir in richtig gehen. Wir haben glücklicherweise einen Mitarbeiter vor Ort, der kommt aus Münchengladbach, der hat aus Asienwissenschaften studiert, der spricht Mandarin, er war sieben Jahre lang in China und hat sich im Endeffekt, ich sag mal mal, auf sein Berufsleben vorbereitet und den konnten wir gewinnen, dass er unser Praktikmanager vor Ort ist im China-Geschäft. Also eine langen Nase, die Mandarin spricht und die Raut im Herzen trägt. Was gibt es da Besseres? Und so sind wir hingegangen und haben, wir haben, sagen wir, den Stachschutz für das Büro gegeben, als wir einen mit einer Stadt, mit der Stadt Zhejiang eine Partnerschaft begründet haben, haben wir gesagt, und jetzt gehen wir vor Ort und stecken das Geld, was wir verdienen, im Markt wieder in den Markt hinein. Wir wollen kein Geld hinausziehen und wollen schauen, wo können wir uns, wo können wir, sagen wir von der Einnahmenseite, den nächsten Schritt anfangen. Das ist ein Geschäft, das passiert nicht von heute auf morgen, das ist langfristig, aber das ist etwas, was dem Fußball-Fan hier überhaupt nicht weh tut, was unsere Fans verstehen. Natürlich fragt der eine, warum gehst du nach China, aber ich glaube, das haben sehr, sehr, das haben alle verstanden, dass das etwas ist, um Möglichkeiten der Zukunft auszuloten, um zum Beispiel die Eigenständigkeit im Verein zu bewahren, nämlich keinen Investor zu holen. Das sind ja genau die Punkte. Du kannst ja nun nicht sagen, ich möchte keinen Investor haben, oder ich möchte den oder das nicht haben. Oder den gelben Balken von der Postbank auf der Brust, den der eine oder andere mal, als die Postbank anfing, zu sponsoren. Nein, es ist ja so, wir wollen ja doch eine gute Mannschaft haben. Wir wollen ja konkurrenzfähig sein. Wir wollen ja positive Ergebnisse gestalten. Und das muss auch finanziert werden. Und deswegen musst du Möglichkeiten finden, ohne ins Wort fallen zu wollen, die vielleicht intelligent sind und dem einen oder anderen nicht weh tun. Was ist denn, wir wollen doch unsere Partner, die wir hier haben, in Mönchengladbach, um den Club herum, auch begleiten, wenn sie nach China gehen, auf der einen Seite. Und auf der anderen Seite gibt es vielleicht den einen oder anderen Chinesen, der sagt dem Weg, ich möchte im Fußball, in Europa, in Deutschland, Fuß fassen.
Da ist es gut, sich positioniert zu haben.
Da musst du dich positionieren, weil der eine oder andere ist vielleicht schon besetzt, der eine oder andere größere Verein. Am langen Ende ist es auch noch eine Aufgabe, als Verein mit Ambitionen immer mal wieder auch international spielen zu wollen, dass man sagt, ich halte die Fahne des deutschen Fußballs auch zum Beispiel in China hoch.
Das ist alles gut verständlich und da ist ja die Borussia auch bei weitem nicht exklusiv, nach China zu gehen. Jetzt ist China aber nicht nur ein Markt, sondern an der Stelle würde mich auch noch interessieren, welche Rolle spielen denn dann nichtökonomische Faktoren bei solchen Entscheidungen? Also zum Beispiel, das kam jetzt vor zwei Wochen, glaube ich, öffentlich, die China-Cabes, wo herauskam, dass über eine Million Uiguren eine muslimische, weitgehend muslimische Minderheit in China in Umerziehungslagern einkassiniert wird. Wir sprechen ja nicht nur vom Markt China, sondern daran hängen ja noch andere Aspekte. Und ohne, dass ich jetzt sagen möchte, jeder Fußballverein muss ein Exempel statuieren. Wir sind alle in einem größeren Kontext eingebettet, aber das gehört ja mit dazu. Und die Borussia steht ja auch für gewisse Werte, die vielleicht nicht immer von den Märkten, in die man da eintritt, und da rede ich jetzt in dem Fall von China, so repräsentiert werden. Was sind ihre Gedanken zu solchen Überlegungen?
Also Sie haben auf der einen Seite, haben Sie ja Recht, indem Sie die Frage stellen. Aber auf der anderen Seite ist es so, dass wir als Beispiel, wir als Borussia Mönchengladbach jetzt, wo wir nach China gehen und das tun, was wir gut tun, nämlich Jungs und Mädchens fußballerisch auszubilden, also das, was wir am besten hier zu Hause in Mönchengladbach machen, auch nach China tragen, zu einer Art Völkerverständigung beitragen. Sie haben ja 100 Prozent Recht, vielleicht ist das ja nicht abschließend. Aber der Sport kann Brücken bauen, und genau muss der Sport Brücken bauen. Aber sich wegzuducken als Sport, zu sagen, weil etwas passiert, was wir nicht gut finden, was nicht gut ist, in dem einen oder anderen Bereich, ohne es werten zu wollen, zu sagen, dann schließe ich das aus. Dann kommt man gar nicht weiter. Es gibt ein wunderschönes Beispiel. Es gibt ein wunderschönes Beispiel. Borussia Mönchengladbach war die erste Mannschaft, die nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg mit einer Militärmaschine nach Israel geflogen ist und Fußball gemacht hat. Wir waren Botschafter über den Fußball. Und wenn man es so sehen will, ist das genau richtig, denn der Sport, der Fußball, kann Brücken schlagen. Der Fußball ist nicht für alles verantwortlich, aber er kann Brücken schlagen. Natürlich kann ich alles negative der Welt immer abstrahieren, immer nur auf… und der Fußball muss es richten. Da ist der Fußball überfordert. Aber die Brücken, die er geschlagen hat, die sind, glaube ich, wichtig und richtig. Aber trotzdem, eh die Diskussion weitergeht. Borussia Mönchengladbach hat sich immer auf die Fahne geschrieben, und das können sie auch wunderbar lesen, für Toleranz. Wir sind unpolitisch. Wir beziehen keine Stellung, denn welche Stellung ist richtig? Entscheidet das der jeweilige der Geschäftsführer, Präsident, Trainer? Soll das der entscheiden? Borussia Mönchengladbach ist unpolitisch. Borussia Mönchengladbach hat die Arme offen für jede Art der Konfession. Jeder Fan, der es uns liebt. Ob es die Hautfarbe, die Herkunft ist. Das ist der Sport. Und dann verbindet der Sport.
Finden Sie nicht, dass man sich da dann auch positionieren müsste, ohne dass – ich fordere jetzt nicht das Extrem, dass ich jetzt sage, Sie müssen, weil jetzt diese Unterdrückung der Uiguren und auch andere Dinge aus China bekannt wurden, nicht Ihr Büro schließen. Aber muss man sich da nicht auch positionieren, um zu verhindern, dass das, was Sie ja auch tun, nämlich eben dem China, zusammen mit dem DFB, Fußball-Know-How zu geben für das Ziel, was China in sportlichem Hinsicht verfolgt, nämlich mal 20 bis 2040, glaube ich, eine WM teilzunehmen und sie wollen auch mal selbst eine ausrichten. Das, was Sie da tun, das spielt ja gleichzeitig dem bestehenden politischen System in China in den Karten. Wir wissen ja, dass der Sport nicht so unpolitisch ist, dass er nicht auch seine Strahlkraft genutzt werden würde. Da müssen wir ja nicht mal bis nach China gehen. Da können wir ja ganz viele andere Beispiele sehen. Wäre es da nicht wichtig, dann auch mal einen Gegenakzent zu setzen, ohne gleich alle Brücken abzubrechen? Das will ich ja gar nicht.
Nochmal, wir bewegen uns jetzt auf einer politischen Diskussion, wo ich…
Aber wenn es um Menschenrechte geht, weiß ich nicht, ob wir so parteipolitisch sind oder ob das nicht…
Nein, das ist, wir bewegen uns ja jetzt in einer Fragestellung, die sehr schwer zu beantworten ist, weil du als Vertreter von Borussia, eines Fußballklubs, eines deutschen Fußballklubs, der dann auch noch in China vor Ort ist, eine Antwort geben sollst. Und ich glaube, die Antwort des Brückenbauens und nämlich des Ankommens bei demjenigen, bei dem Jungen, bei dem Mädchen, bei den Fußballerinnen und Fußballern, das ist ja schon mal ein Riesenschritt. Das ist ja schon mal die Brücke, die gebaut wird. Und jetzt frage ich ganz ketzerlich, was wäre es denn, wenn wir uns positionieren und sagen, wir finden das nicht gut? Das wird nicht böse gemeint, das würde irgendwo verpuffen.
Ja, das wäre aber vielleicht…
Oder wir würden uns zurückziehen, wir sagen, wir, jetzt machen wir Borussia Mönchengladbach nichts mehr mit China. Ist doch lächerlich.
Na, warum? Wäre das nicht vielleicht genau das?
Dann sind wir auf einem Pfad, dass wir sagen würden, die politische Diskussion A, die lohnt es sich zu sprechen und die politische Diskussion B lohnt es sich vielleicht nicht zu sprechen. Aber das ist eine Wertung. Deswegen wollte ich das Verständnis, sagen wir, schüren. Bei uns in unserem Kodex, den wir bei Borussia Mönchengladbach haben, das ist der Borussenkodex, 2.0 sogar, den haben die Fänz sich gegeben. Und da drin ist verankert, wir sind unpolitisch. Das ist dann schwer. Wenn man vielleicht Sachen, die man selber privat anders entscheiden würde, aber aufgrund der Gesinnung dieses Vereines dann so zu gestalten, denn vielleicht ist ja, jetzt lasst mal bitte mal China weg, es gibt andere politische Diskussionen, dann sagen sie vielleicht, das finde ich gut, ich sage, ich fände das genauso gut. Aber es gibt immer einen Gegenpol, der sagt, ne, aber das darf Borussia auf keinen Fall machen.
Den gibt es definitiv, aber vielleicht gibt es ja einen gemeinsamen Nenner und damit würde ich dann auch jetzt zum Schluss kommen, auch wenn ich noch lange mit ihnen reden könnte.
Steht oben wunderbar.
Gegen Rassismus für Toleranz.
Und für Borussia. Das steht bei uns unterm Tribünen-Dach und das sind so die wichtigen Werte.
Genau, das ist der gemeinsame Nenner, auf den ich hin wollte, die Menschenrechte. Und da würde mich jetzt noch als abschließendes Thema interessieren, Sie haben ja gerade auch noch eine andere große Aufgabe vor sich, nämlich einen neuen Trikotsponsor zu finden, wo sich mir persönlich die Frage stellt, was ist schwieriger, diese Aufgabe zu erfüllen oder deutscher Meister zu werden?
Also ganz im Ernst, es ist eine spaßige Frage, Sie kriegen eine spaßige Antwort, aber nein, lassen Sie bitte, jeder kann träumen, aber am 13. Spieltag träumt Borussia nicht von der deutschen Meisterschaft.
Wir wollen jetzt hier keine Meisterschaftsschleppseile raus. Aber spielen denn dann solche Überlebungen, wie ich sie hatte, bei denen mir völlig klar ist, ich komme jetzt aus einer komplett anderen Einflugschneise, als Sie in Ihrem kaufmännischen Denken logischerweise haben. Aber spielen solche Überlegungen auch bei der Auswahl eines Trikot-Sponsors eine Rolle, der ja den prominentesten Platz bei einem Fußballverein neben dem Stadion hat. Und da haben Sie sich schon festgelegt, das wird nicht passieren. Das hier wird der Borussia-Park bleiben, allerhöchstens mal vielleicht ein Zusatz. Aber spielen da solche Überlegungen auch eine Rolle, dass man sagt, zum Beispiel wir wollen nur mit Unternehmen zusammenarbeiten, die sich dem Aktionsplan für UN-Menschenrechte sich einzusetzen angeschlossen haben, den ja auch die deutsche Bundesregierung initiiert hat.
Also sie haben vollkommen recht. Man sollte auf jeden Fall – oder das macht Borussia Mönchengladbach – neben dem Geld, worum es sich fast immer nur geht, dreht in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung, ist der Hauptsponsor ein Bestandteil vom Club, der dringt stark in deine DNA ein. Und der Hauptsponsor will ja auch, dass das, was Borussia Mönchengladbach verkörpert, dass das auch auf ihn strahlt. Deswegen muss ein Sponsoring immer auf Augenhöhe sein. Ich kann das ganz klar beantworten. Es gibt verschiedene Farben. Dann ist das halt so auf der einen Seite. Die Diskussionen haben wir geführt. Aber du musst schon Unternehmen haben, die zu dir passen am langen Ende. Und das impliziert dann ihre Fragestellung.
Also das heißt, sie haben das auf dem Schirm und man denkt dann auch so.
Heutzutage ist das Gewinnen eines Hauptsponsors ja gar nicht mehr nur das Gewinnen eines Partners, der dir Geld gibt für Präsenzen, sei es auf der Brust, auf den Banden oder wo auch immer. Sondern am langen Ende kann er dich auf ganz anderen Gebieten auch viel weiterbringen. Was weiß ich, wenn wir über Digitalisierung reden und dergleichen. Dann sind das vielleicht Softfacts, die am Ende des Tages sich viel mehr auszahlen.
Dann bin ich sehr gespannt, was Sie da präsentieren werden, wann auch immer. Manche Hörerinnen und Hörer werden das hier bestimmt erst hören, wenn der Trikotsponsor schon verkündet wurde. Sagen Sie mir abschließend noch die Borussia Mönchengladbach im Jahr 2030. Wie sieht die Bundesliga aus und welche Rolle spielt Borussia da losgelöst von Tabellenplätzen? Mir geht es jetzt nicht um irgendwelche Titelfragen, sondern wie stellen Sie sich das Geschäft Fußball in zehn Jahren vor?
Erstmal hoffe ich, dass der Fußball Fußball bleibt. Ich hoffe, dass wir gerade, wenn wir über die Champions League sprechen, nicht darüber sprechen, dass das Qualifizieren zur Champions League fundamentiert zementiert ist, so wie es gerade von der ECR so ein wenig in Fokus genommen worden ist, sondern dass gerade der Ausgang in der jeweiligen Nationalen Liga die Qualifikation zur Champions League, zur Euro League ausmacht. Das Brot- und Buttergeschäft soll der Fußball, der nationale Fußball bleiben, die Bundesliga, der DFB-Pokal, alles das, was wir so lieben. Und die Sahne, das Sahnehäubchen obendrauf, das sind die internationalen Wettbewerbe und die musst du erreichen über den nationalen Liga-Ausgang am Ende einer Saison. Das ist ein wesentlicher Bestandpunkt und dass wir im Endeffekt den Fußball, so wie wir ihn haben, auch weiterhin lieben können.
Okay, das war jetzt eine halbe Antwort, aber weil wir schon drüber über die Zeit sind, lasse ich sie damit davon kommen. Ich hätte noch ganz lange mit ihm weitersprechen können. Vielen herzlichen Dank, Stephan Schippers.
Danke, tschüss. Sehr gerne, tschüss.
Und da war es vorbei, unser Gespräch mit Stephan Schippers. Viel zu schnell natürlich, vor allem für eingefleischte Rasenfunkhörerinnen und Hörer. Aber so ist das eben. Man kann nicht mit jedem vier Stunden sprechen, auch wenn man es definitiv mit jedem gerne machen würde und es auch jeder Gesprächsgast verdient hätte, wie ich finde. Wer weiß, vielleicht gibt es ja irgendwann mal einen Teil zwei. Wir hoffen, dass euch dieser – na ja, fast schon Quickie – in Tribünengespräch ausmaßen dennoch gefallen hat, dass ihr interessante neue Dinge erfahren habt. Und einen Hinweis möchte ich noch gerne machen. Am Ende von allen Folgen weise ich gerne auf Podcast-Episoden hin, die mir gut gefallen haben. Und da hat Stephan Schippers die Überleitung und den Anstoß für gegeben, was ich hier im Tribünengespräch empfehlen könnte. Erinnert ihr euch an den Moment, in dem er gesagt hat, dass Borussia Mönchengladbach die erste Mannschaft war, die aus Gründen der Volkeverständigung nach Israel gefahren ist und dort Spiele bestritten hat? Diese Information hatte ich schon. Warum hatte ich die? Dafür ist allein ein Podcast verantwortlich, nämlich Mensch, Frau Nora. Sowieso ein sehr empfehlenswertes Format. Und in der Folge Diplomaten in kurzen Hosen mit Jessica Baller, die jetzt auch neulich in der Schlusskonferenz, also wenn ihr das jetzt zeitnah hört, ihr Debüt gegeben hat im Rasenfunk, wurde genau diese Episode aufgearbeitet. Kann ich euch allen sehr, sehr ans Herz legen. Eine sehr tolle Folge lohnt sich und es ist ja auch ein interessantes Stück Sportgeschichte. Ja und damit sind wir am Ende dieses 39. Tribünengesprächs angelangt. Wenn ihr Lust habt, könnt ihr jetzt natürlich auch unter kiosk.rasenfunk.de shoppen. Ihr könnt den Rasenfunk anders unterstützen unter rasenfunk.de/. Unterstützen gibt es alle Informationen dazu und sollte euch der Rasenfunk bisher neu gewesen sein, dann guckt doch mal, was wir sonst noch so viele Folgen gemacht haben. Es würde mich wundern, wenn da nicht für jeden was dabei wäre. Über 800 Stunden Rasenfunk. Macht es gut, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Bis bald mal wieder.
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.